-Guys, before we go on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit
in the commercial breaks
-Oh.
-and we want to make sure
that we mention all of them,
so it's time
for "Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
♪♪
-Starbucks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Apple...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Monster energy drinks...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Laughter, awws, and applause ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
And finally...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's all
[ Cheering ]
for "Tonight Show Sponsors."